レッドカーペット歩くんですよね
いまからレッドカーペット歩くんですけども
でその、レッドカーペットの歩くステージのまんなかにMCの方がこう立っているんですけども
僕はその神聖なレッドカーペットの場で周りにもすごい沢山の人がいるんですけども
その中で僕はいかにMCの人にバレずに唐揚げを食べれるかという
はじめ）ちょっと普通はバレますよね周りは
スタッフ）周りはバレますよね
食ってたら普通にばれちゃうんで、
MＣのBooさん、MCの方にだけばれないように
こっそりいかにそのレッドカーペットという敷居の高い場所で
僕がからあげを食べれるかっていう
伝説に今回挑戦してみようと思います
スタッフ）全然分かんないっすね
はじめ）わかんないっすよね
スタッフ）分かんないっす全然わかんないっす
はっはっは
いつでも出せるような状況が大事っすよ
スタッフ）そうですねOKっす
よーし食うぞ
Ｂｏｏさんがどこを見てるかですよね
こっちばっかり見てるともう...
いってきます！
はじめ）食べます？
Ｂｏｏ）何？
はじめ）遠慮しないでどうぞ
Ｂｏｏ）じか!?
はじめしゃちょー大学卒業おめでとうございます
はじめ）あー、ありがとうございます
Ｂｏｏ）え、大学卒業して何してんの今
はじめ）今は、まあ家を守りつつ
観客）スプラトゥーン！スプラトゥーン！
はじめ）え？　スプラトゥーンを
Ｂｏｏ）そー　　　観客）遊戯王！遊技王！
はじめ）遊技王を
観客）ベイブレード！ベイブレード！
はじめ）あ、ベイブレードを